Uber's Travis kalanick epitomizes the
frat boy libertarian approach in Silicon
Valley he has no respect for government
no respect for his employees no respect
for a critical journalists who go after
his company indeed there was a recent
case where one of his VPS suggested that
they would go after one of the
journalists the female journalist called
Sarah Lacy and Kalani did absolutely
nothing didn't even dismiss this VP so
colonic epitomizes that that that
libertarianism he used to have an EIN
dran photo on his Twitter page more
seriously though although that's also a
serious critique Lewbert epitomizes the
reason why the internet is not the
answer at the moment we have this free
market ideology that says all you need
are platforms that the uber platform for
cabs will replace the old archaic
monopolies of the 20th century but of
course uber represents a much more
dangerous monopoly the reason why uber
is valued at 40 billion dollars the
reason why billions of dollars of
Silicon Valley and Wall Street money
have poured into uber it because it's a
play at actually controlling the entire
global cab transportation industry uber
is not for the people it's not for the
consumers for uber employees it's for
Travis kalanick to dominate that market
it becomes the dominant platform and
with that domination it's a really very
scary prospect already ubers behavior i
think is untenable and very morally
questionable for example that uber
market is so dependent on the free
market the term when it rains when
there's a snowstorm on New Year's Eve on
Thanksgiving on any occasion where
there's excessive demand for cabs goober
goober fares go up 10 12 X there's no
regulation there's no defense let me
give you the best anecdote I think of
all I was in Detroit a few months ago
got into the back of a cab
african-american driver had five cabs of
his own would have been one of those
small businessmen who'll be swept away
by uber hard-working guy very aunty you
be told me a story his bride
in law got out of jail done 10 years for
manslaughter when he came out of jail I
said to him what they do come and work
for you said no I can't employ him the
regulations are against me employing
someone who's done 10 years for
manslaughter but that brother-in-law got
a job with uber there's no checks on
ober drivers so when you get into the
back of an uber cab you can be attacked
they're more and more cases in the bay
area of uber drivers bullying their
customers even physically attacking them
so all these all this free market
libertarian ideology this idea that the
government is the enemy that regulation
is the enemy is lending itself to a
system whereby uber isn't regulated
isn't controlled can charge us anything
they want can exploit us as customers
booba is even exploiting its drivers it
doesn't employ them it doesn't give them
any security it doesn't allow them to
join unions and the uber drivers are
indeed themselves striking against you
but because they see it as exploitative
so on every level whether it's the
driver the customer the pre DD that the
legacy cab companies the local
authorities uber is exploitative and bad
news it's the reason why without
regulation the internet is not the
answer
you